they are the most
some of the most challenging scenes that
have been encountered by frontline
officers by wider emergency services
and most certainly by the public
in terms of the scenes in the street
they're unheard of in nearly all our
cities but especially a city like
plymouth
which is whilst a naval city
predominantly an extraordinarily
peaceful city then we can talk about
kiam as a key community within a city we
can identify our sub-communities in this
committee down to streets and roads so
bidding drive is a community within a
community and that granularity
was tested last night in terms of the
resilience of that community because the
courage of it you know it was very
uncertain times and the community
supported us unequivocally
it will be tested over the coming days
undoubtedly there will be upset and
anger and we will stand side by side
with our communities and the council and
our mps during that time can you give me
some idea of the scene that greeted you
um so the timeline
and there was
if i'm confused i didn't mean
so officers originally called without
firearms and are attending then it comes
out as firearms all officers continue to
deploy
the first officers on scene encountered
the child that had been shot in the
street with the adult using what is
described as a pump action shotgun
i won't expand on that but i think most
people can imagine what that was like
for arriving officers further along
bidding drive we then have two
injured members of the public as more
officers arrived
and then they're pointing where mr
davidson has gone
further officers are attending and then
in caintin encountering a further
murdered male and female and then
ultimately mr davidson himself who's
taking his own life
how did it start
it starts we believe with a domestic
related incident between mr davidson and
a lady who lived at the premises
it's a familial relationship but at the
moment working with the family want to
make sure all the family know
but that then comes out onto the street
as as i say we don't know the motivation
of mr davidson in our society tragedy we
do live with domestic related homicide
then suicide
we've had one recently within the force
area of homicide followed by suicide but
we've never in my time had homicide
followed by a
rampaging firearms attack on random
members of the public
and then taking one's life that is
without president in my time as chief
constable there were two people who were
shot and injured
um but there were others who witnessed
some of those murders how are they
traumatized extremely traumatized and
i think whilst we're trained and we are
trained to run towards danger and deal
with it
that's why the commission is made
available
for those who witnessed and we've got
specialist officers with them and
liaison officers and will make referrals
if they wish
what was upsetting i understand it in a
digital age that images were shared to
people who've opened things on their
phone not expecting to see what they
they they found and that's why
you'll make the number available but why
the the commissioner said anyone can
phone victim support
these are particularly traumatizing
images
what do you know about jake davidson
we know that he's 22 years old we know
that devlin cornwall police have a
firearms license granted to him um i can
tell you that we have literally many
thousands of firearms license holders
within the force area they're regularly
reviewed in legislation but we do take
firearms licenses away from people when
they come to notice the police or family
members raise concerns later to restore
them once we're assured that will form
part of the inquiry when was it granted
was it granted correctly was it ever
removed was it ever restored and that
will be made available to you the
coroner and we're working with the
independent office of police complaints
on that do you know yet whether he held
a license last night
as i understand it martin right now he
was still a licensed holder last night
how do you go about establishing motive
i mean what are you doing in terms of
investigating him
so testing him
yourselves not least already looking at
his social media accounts we'll be
looking at any phone accounts clearly
speaking with his family members members
of the community knew him perhaps where
he worked building a life picture of of
mr davidson looking early in life any
motivations or indications that we may
have missed or could have been spotted
but i don't now want to do the call to
hindsight we need to understand what
drew him to attend we believe a family
member's home to take a life there
and then
most unusually to go onto the street to
do what he did
we always so impressed when people go
from
call to arrival at an incident
had this been anywhere else in the force
area
the response time to firearms instance
in forces outside of major urban forces
is usually in half hour and 45 minute
windows
a six minute response time is
extraordinarily rare and i believe it's
perceived by the public to be the norm
and sooner or later something might
happen where that's not the normal last
night my officers armed and unarmed ran
towards danger at some point knowing
firearms were there british policing
does that and i'm extraordinarily brave
of them they're proud of them no matter
what comes out in the future
the british public should understand
that in a four thousand square mile
geography
a six minute response time was
extraordinarily professional but in many
ways extraordinarily fortunate in what
were most unfortunate and tragic
circumstances do you believe that quick
response time saved other lives
we won't know
whether
mr davidson heard us heard the sirens
whether he had saw had seen i don't know
that may come out
but no doubt
we would discover in time
um what i do know right now is that the
people of kiam
and my officers and the responding blue
light agencies were extraordinarily
brave and courageous last time